damit kommen wir jetzt zum bereich
digitales und verkehr und hier auch
schon den minister volker wissing sie
haben es vielleicht schon gemerkt vorher
wurde das bundesministerium für verkehr
und digitales genannte jetzt gibt es
einen zahlendreher für digitales umfeld
das die totale krieg also praktisch mehr
aufmerksamkeit weil sein bester spieler
steht mehrheit zusammen bundesminister
für eine frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die monate der
pandemie haben deutlich gemacht wie
wichtig es für uns ist uns frei bewegen
und jederzeit miteinander kommunizieren
zu können
mobilität und kommunikation sind
grundbedürfnisse der menschen wir
brauchen sie um uns und unsere ideen zu
entfalten die große aufgabe lautet jetzt
dafür zu sorgen dass wir unsere
grundbedürfnisse klimaneutral erfüllen
können und zwar so schnell wie möglich
klimaschutz muss umfassend und
sektorübergreifend gedacht werden
wir brauchen einen starken frau eine
starke bahn klimaneutrale lkw schiffe
und flugzeuge attraktive und sichere rad
und fußwege und im pkw-bereich ganz klar
den umstieg auf klimaneutrale mobilität
da gibt es auch nichts mehr zu
diskutieren oder abzuwarten es ist
unsere aufgabe der welt zu zeigen dass
unsere soziale marktwirtschaft mit ihrer
wettbewerbsordnung auch ökologische
fragen am besten beantworten kann
die wollen unserer verantwortung
gegenüber künftigen generationen gerecht
werden das heißt für uns dass wir alles
tun werden die klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen wir streben deshalb mindestens
15 millionen elektrische pkw bis 2030
die kurzfristig verfügbare klimaneutrale
mobilität im individualverkehr ist die
elektromobilität wenn wir schnell co2
reduzieren wollen müssen wir sie stärker
nutzen wir wollen die klimaschutzziele
im verkehrsbereich einhalten die
elektromobilität im pkw-bereich es dafür
ein wichtiger baustein
gleiches gilt aber auch für strom
basierte kraftstoffe uns nicht nur im
verkehr auch im schiffsverkehr bei den
nutzfahrzeugen und natürlich auch in den
bestands flotten der pkw jeder beitrag
zur co2 reduktion ist wichtig
und meine damen und herren mobilität
muss sich auch in zukunft
technologieoffen weiter entwickeln wir
wissen heute nicht welche
technologischen chancen uns die zukunft
bietet verfügbare technologie nutzen
darf deshalb nie heißen ein verbot neuer
technologien auszusprechen
mobilität ist vielfältig deswegen können
wir nicht alles auf einen antrieb
umstellen wir dürfen den menschen das
leben nicht erschweren im gegenteil
nachhaltige mobilität muss einfach sein
bequem und bezahlbar für alle der ausbau
der schnell ladeinfrastruktur ist für
mich eines der drängendsten themen
niemand kauft sich ein e-auto wenders
stunden an der wahl an der ladesäule
warten muss zudem müssen öffentliche
ladesäulen für jeden unbürokratisch
nutzbar sein und
klimaschutz kann nur funktionieren wenn
die breite mitte der gesellschaft ihnen
mit trägt deswegen müssen wir immer im
blick balken die mittel besteht aus
unterschiedlichen menschen mit sehr
unterschiedlichen mobilitätsbedürfnissen
jedem und jeder ein entsprechendes
angebot zu machen dass sie als
fortschritt empfinden ist unsere aufgabe
und die digitalisierung kann uns hier
enorm helfen dank ihr können wir ganz
neue mobilitätsangebote entwickelt die
individuell auf die situation der
menschen passen aber auch in anderen
bereichen ist die digitalisierung der
entscheidende schlüssel um beim
klimaschutz voranzukommen mit ihrer
hilfe können wir infrastruktur besser
planen besser bauen und effizienter
nutzen sie ist ein muster für unsere
wirtschaft erst recht für unsere
verwaltung
digitalisierung erleichtert unseren
alltag und unser arbeitsleben mit ihrer
hilfe läuft es effizienter kürzer und
ressourcenschonender klar ist dafür
brauchen wir ein leistungsfähiges
internet und verlässlichen mobilfunk und
zwar überall dort wo menschen leben und
arbeiten
wir werden deshalb eine umfassende
gigabit strategie erarbeiten schlanke
digitale antrags und
genehmigungsverfahren entwickeln
alternative verlegetechnik informieren
und ein bundeseinheitliches gigabit
grundbuch aufbauen bei all diesen
vorhaben baue ich auf ihre unterstützung
holpriges internet und mobilfunk löcher
sind für einen wirtschaftsstandort wie
deutschland nicht akzeptabel
mit dem
mit dem g7 vorsitzen wird deutschland
zudem in der digitalisierung ein starkes
signal setzen für offene standards und
diversität für digitale innovation sowie
unternehmerische und gesellschaftliche
initiative
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
mobilfunk und glasfaser schienenwege
straßen radwege brücken tunnel das alles
sind die lebensadern einem modernen
gesellschaft deshalb werden wir kräftig
investieren übrigens erstmals mehr in
die china als in die straße aber eben
auch in die straße und wir müssen
schneller werden beim planen genehmigen
und bauen die a45 zeigt uns gegenwärtig
die folgen mangel der vorausschauende
planung
deshalb werden wir die verfahren
beschleunigen und mit den ländern einen
pakt schließen wichtig ist dass unsere
investition schnell wirkung zeigen eines
haben wir nicht zeit zum schluss meine
damen und herren wünsche ich mir etwas
ganz grundsätzliches mehr verständnis
für die bedürfnisse und die sichtweise
des anderen etwas weniger bereitschaft
sich sofort und ständig zu empören wenn
jemand von einem verkehrsträger spricht
heißt das nicht dass er andere gering
schätzt ich bin überzeugt dass wir nur
besser werden wenn wir unterschiedliche
blickwinkel auf die themen zu lassen
vieles müssen wir gemeinsam anpacken und
schneller werden und immer nah an den
bedürfnissen der menschen bleiben
klimaschutz ist eine daueraufgabe für
uns alle dass wir heute auf den weg
bringen muss dauerhaft von mehrheiten
getragen werden das schaffen wir nur
gemeinsam
wenn wir die menschen mitnehmen und
ihnen ein attraktives angebot machen
vielen dank
unter diesen war das
[Musik]
natürlich ein muss die ladesäulen
infrastruktur für e autos ausgebaut
werden muss weitere aufgaben wenn jetzt
bestimmt in der debatte hier angerissen
als erster spricht thomas bareiß
verkehrspolitische sprecher der union in
liebe kollegen die kollegen sagen
bundesminister dr wissen auch im namen
der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
herzlichen glückwunsch zu ihrer neuen
aufgabe zu übernehmen mit dem
bundesverkehrsministerium ein gut
bestelltes haus
hinaus wünschen wir ihnen viel erfolg
und gottes reichen segen ich glaube das
brauchen sie auch denn ich hatte den
eindruck dass männchen ihrer neuen
koalition ich kenne so viel applaus
spendet ich glaube auch da müssen noch
etwas überzeugungsarbeit für das ein und
andere leisten offengestanden uns als
cdu und csu kommt vieles von dem was sie
vorgetragen haben sehr bekannt vor
minister die listen viele fragen auf die
ihr vorgänger auf den weg gebracht hat
deshalb werden sie feststellen dass wir
sie in vielen nicht in allen aber in
vielen bereichen auch wohlwollend
begleiten werden für manchen vorhaben
wollen sie ihm noch über das hinaus
gehen was ihr vorgänger gemacht hat
allerdings beschreiben sie nicht wie sie
die notwendigen mehr ausgaben
finanzieren wollen in diesem punkt ist
ihre sogenannte fortschritts kreation er
ein großer rückschritt meine damen haben
[Applaus]
ihre kolleginnen kollegen für die cdu
csu fraktion ist mobilität ein ausdruck
von freiheit
freiheit ist ein grundbedürfnis aller
menschen und deshalb muss mobilität auch
in zukunft für jeden wo auf dem land
oder in der stadt auch bezahlbar sein
dazu habe ich nichts gehört von
innenminister wir sind dankbar
es ist dankbar dass keine grüne
verbotskultur ins bundesverkehrsminister
eingezogen ist für alle wissen verbote
schaden mehr als dass sie nützen ich
kann sie nur ermuntern halten sie stand
bei forderungen wieder ein generelles
tempolimit es bringt nichts fürs klima
und auch nichts für die
verkehrssicherheit auch in anderen
bereichen
auch in anderen bereichen haben wir hohe
erwartungen an sie so effektiver
klimaschutz wir werden sie daran messen
ob sie ihre hohen ziele auch wirklich im
verkehrssektor einhalten wir alle wissen
eine ohne verkehrssektor gibt es keinen
klimaschutz julia und sieht sich deshalb
ein für den ausbau und reduzierung der
schienen personennahverkehrs ausbau von
öpnv
cherry mobility natürlich auch den
radverkehr die neuausrichtung des
luftverkehrs und vor allem eine enge und
digitale verzahnung unserer
verkehrsträger
viele bürgerinnen bürger werden das auto
sind für das auto unverzichtbare hat es
wohl das ganze stolz seiner
regierungserklärung vor wenigen wochen
gesagt in den letzten vier jahren haben
wir es geschafft die zahl der
elektroautos in deutschland zu
verzehnfachen meinen dank aber auch eine
tiefe und ethische kraftstoff
juhls die brennstoffzelle wasserstoff
sind wichtige säulen für eine
nachhaltige und klimafreundliche
mobilität ohne e views und aktiv
kraftstoffe geht es nicht herr minister
denn auch der pkw-bestand braucht eine
klimafreundliche perspektive das war
bisher heute immer ihre meinung auch die
ihres paten auch der fdp umso
überraschter war ich heute oder morgen
als ich die taten spiel gelesen hab sie
verabschieden sich heute morgen von 11
uhr sind setzen sich bei pkw ist nur
noch für die elektro
elektromobilität ein so schnell ist doch
kein minister innerhalb weniger wochen
wenn es entscheidende punkt seines
ressorts umgefallen weil dann das kommt
einem wort auch gleich aber nicht
denn bisher
dies hat die fdp immer betont ein ende
von bestimmten technologien wie dem
effizienten brenner wird es mit ihnen
nicht geben und jetzt hören wir von
ihrem koalitionspartner diese woche im
verkehrsausschuss da schon entschieden
centers dem verbrennungsmotor aus
entgegen steht ja was nun herr minister
kann hier nur fragen deutschland als
wichtigsten industrienationen europa und
bisher weltweit erfolgreich sowie
standort kann sich keine bundesregierung
leisten die nicht weiß was sie will die
8000 beschäftigten oder wie brecht
brauche wenn ein minister auf denen sie
sich auch verlassen können da witzigen
ansagen
verlässlichkeit braucht es auch bei den
investitionen in die infrastruktur
64 prozent in die schiene investiert
ich habe selber gesagt dieses jahres
erst einmal mehr in die schiene alte die
straße wir haben entschieden
personennahverkehr steht mittel vor
vierfach bis die nächsten drei jahren
die stelle alle sollen zwei milliarden
euro wasserstoff strategie sieben euro
in allen bereichen qualität gibt es hier
große chance nächsten jahr wir erwarten
dass sie diesen nachhaltigen pfad weiter
gehen den erhalt die erweiterung und den
ausbau in allen bereichen weiter stark
voran drehen das betrifft auch den
erforderlichen ausbau der maroden oder
wein brücke auf der a44 bei lüdenscheid
hier erwarten wir einen schnellen und
zuverlässigen fahrplan für den ersatzbau
das muss zur chefsache werden das
erwarten die menschen vor ort zu recht
weil waren sie auch weiterhin
unterstützen hier können sie zeigen hier
können sie zeigen minister die
beschleunigung der planung und umsetzung
ganz konkret vor ort auch aussehen wird
im nächsten jahr hier werden dass sie
auch noch mal ganz konkret messen
minister wir bieten eine konstruktive
und offene zusammenarbeit an sind wohl
der menschen und sowohl eines
erfolgreichen industriestandorts
deutschland herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner in der debatte
bundesministerium für digitales und
verkehr ist dass müller stoffe dritten
vorsitzenden der spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meiner
lieben damen und herren die pandemie ja
wir sind angesprochen prägt unser
alltagsleben und die bereiche verkehr
und digitales stehen ist symbolhaft für
die einschränkungen und belastungen die
damit einhergehen egal ob der weg zur
arbeit zum einkaufen oder das hoffest
wir erleben dass wir uns auf unsere
infrastrukturen verlassen können müssen
um solche krisen erfolgreich zu
bewältigen und wir spüren wir brauchen
mehr widerstandsfähigkeit mehr
leistungsfähigkeit aber auch mehr
kapazitäten und wir brauchen
qualifizierte und motivierte beschäftigt
wird deshalb möchte ich ausdrücklich
denen danken die sich jeden tag in die
bresche werfen damit unsere
daseinsvorsorge funktionieren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen diese
legislaturperiode steht für ausbau und
modernisierung unserer zentralen
infrastruktur und herr bareiß
ich fand die rede ist schon etwas
seltsam und auch ein stück weit anmaßend
nach zwölf jahren nach zwölf jahren
bayerischer herrschaft im
verkehrsministerium und mit der
vorgelegten bilanz übrigens auch bei 45
hätte ich mir etwas mehr demut schon
gewünscht sei angemessen gewesen
meine damen und herren verkehr ab
digitalisierung und energie sind die
zentralen bereiche wirtschaft für den
klimaschutz und auch für den
gesellschaftlichen fortschritt sie
prägen ganz maßgeblich das zusammenleben
in unserem land nicht nur in den städten
sondern insbesondere auch in den
ländlichen regionen
mobilität für jeden eine flächendeckende
digitale infrastruktur energie stehen
für die soziale teilhabe und auch für
zukunftsfähige beschäftigung das eine
lässt sich um anderen nicht trennen sie
sind kernbereich des strukturwandels
gehen haben wir unumkehrbar begonnen und
nun kommt es darauf an dass wir ihn zum
besten menschen voranbringen dazu gehört
vor allem dass wir schneller werden und
umsetzung wir verlieren immer noch viel
zu viel zeit das zur verfügung stehende
geld auch zügig in wirklich reale
investitionen umzusetzen das gilt für
den gigaba gigabit rassen aus genauso
wie für die lade und
verkehrsinfrastruktur wir müssen endlich
ein investitionsstau auflösen und in
zukunftsfähigen ausbau unserer
infrastrukturen als
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
begreifen und dafür auch einen großen
gesellschaftlichen konsens herstellen
wir müssen weg von der verhinderung ist
kultur ein hin zu einer kultur des
möglichen der koalitionsvertrag spricht
eine klare sprache planungs bestätigung
steht auf der agenda ganz oben es kann
nicht sein dass wir die fertigstellung
zentraler bahnstrecken von jahrzehnt zu
jahrzehnt weiter nach hinten schieben
wir werden daher die vereinbarung aus
dem koalitionsvertrag
von der stichtagsregelung
bundeseinheitliche ausnahmeregelung bis
hin zum maßnahmen gesetz konsequent
nutzen und unsere ausbauziele auch zu
erreichen
die wir kolleginnen und kollegen wir
wollen die beiden politiker in den
öffentlichen personennahverkehr noch
stärker ins zentrum der verkehrspolitik
da kommt ja vier jahre stellen und dazu
gehört dass wir die digitalisierung der
waren schneller voranbringen allein
dadurch sind ohne lange
planungsverfahren bis zu 25 prozent mehr
kapazität auf der schiene zu erreichen
gleiches gilt für den spnv eine bessere
und zukunftsfähige finanzen stellung für
den betrieb die voranschreitende
digitalisierung und ein besseres angebot
gerade auch unter fleischer brauchen ein
klares bekenntnis von uns übrigens auch
für investitionen dafür
stabilisierungspaket für den öpnv im
koalitionsvertrag den wir auf allen vier
doch allen ebenen schnell mit leben
erfüllen müssen
meine damen und herren
unser leitbild ist die bezahlbare
mobilität für jeden nicht gegen das auto
sondern intelligent intelligente
verknüpfung aller verkehrsträger wir
müssen angebote für die lebensrealität
der menschen schaffen darin fragt zu
recht warum alle vom bsv rehden aber bei
ihm nur zweimal am tag der bus fährt und
die familie wundert sich dass sie sich
ein elektrofahrzeug kaufen soll es aber
kaum bezahlbaren modell auf dem markt
gibt und die nächste leute sollte zwölf
kilometer entfernt ist
gleiches gilt für digital ausbauen eine
flächendeckende leistungsfähige und
sichere digitale infrastruktur
aussetzung für wirtschaftliche
entwicklung soziale und
gesellschaftliche teilhabe modernes
arbeiten und land sowie für
fortschrittliche mobilität all das hängt
an einem konsequenten ausbau der
digitalen infrastruktur und wir wollen
dass die verwaltung in deutschland
endlich ein niveau bei der
digitalisierung erreicht wofür man sich
internationalen nicht mehr schämen muss
die digitalisierung der verwaltung
steckt vielerorts immer noch in den
kinderschuhen das ist ein
investitionshindernis nicht
bürgerfreundlich und verlängert und die
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren
wir brauchen eine zeitgemäße
leistungsfähige und nutzerorientierte
digitale verwaltung die nicht hemmschuh
sondern zentraler standort vorteil ist
lieber kollege wissing und das gilt auch
für den kollegen habe sie können sie mir
ausrichten alle drei bereiche
digitalisierung verkehr unter ausbau
erneuerbaren energien hängen eng
zusammen bedingen sich gegenseitig und
müssen zusammen gedacht und umgesetzt
werden wir werden sie dabei unterstützen
wir werden sie unterstützen damit wir
unsere ziele auch als koalition
erreichen und wir werden sie konstruktiv
fordern wenn es darum geht auf welchen
weg wird es tun die zeiten dass man
müsste man wobei ich komme zum schluss
dass ob haben wir mit dem
koalitionsvertrag beantwortet nun geht
es um das wie und vor allem und dass man
als um die umsetzung ich freue mich auf
die zusammenarbeit vielen dank
die studieren im aaseebad ist joanna
krupa die digital politische sprecherin
der fdp-fraktion
bevor sie zum eigentlichen thema komme
eine kurze persönliche anmerkung von mir
die ausgrenzung von umkämpften wie sie
seit dieser woche im bundestag
praktiziert wird und draußen bei der
gesellschaft muss ein sofortiges ende
finden das hat mit gesundheitsvorsorge
nichts aber auch gar nichts mehr zu tun
sondern ist reine schikane und
brandmarkung von den umkämpften das
gesunde menschen in deutschland nicht
mehr normal leben und arbeiten können
ist eine schande meine damen und herren
aber bevor hier die aufregung zu groß
geld ich weiß ja sie können mit der
freiheit wenig anfangen hier komme ich
zum eigentlichen thema meine rede die
digitalisierung szene der ampel
koalition die neue regierung hat sich
viel vorgenommen für die nächsten vier
jahre viele versprechen wohl klingende
sätze das alles kennen wir schon von den
letzten vier jahren und auch da war die
spd mit an der regierung der
wissenschaftliche beirat des
wirtschaftsministeriums kommt in seinem
gutachten zu dem schluss dass
deutschland während dieser regierung
sowohl beim ausbau der digitalen
infrastruktur als auch beim einsatz
digitaler
technologien und dienstleistungen hinter
viele andere oecd länder zurückgefallen
ist die haben also noch nicht mehr
unseren standard halten können wir sind
zurückgefallen aber nun soll alles
besser werden schließlich gibt es nur
neue koalitionspartner der netzausbau
soll fortan beziehen werden die
verwaltung endlich digitalisiert es soll
mehr geforscht werden mehr für die cyber
sicherheit getan werden passwörter wiki
blog chain und crypto wir dürfen
natürlich auch nicht fehlen kurz fast
alles was man sich im bereich
digitalisierung wünschen kann soll an
werden das klingt gut das ist bitter
nötig aber schauen wir uns doch mal an
wie glaubwürdig das ist und werfen wir
dabei einen blick auf die parteien die
dieses versprechen abgeben allen voran
die fdp in der letzten wahlperiode das
thema digitalisierung hier wirklich rauf
und runter gespielt hat eine der
zentralen forderungen war ein digital
ministerium eine vor die die haltestelle
die den überblick hat und die
digitalisierung in deutschland managt
und was kommt in dieser
legislaturperiode nicht ein digital
ministerium stattdessen kümmert sich
minister wissen um digitales und verkehr
aber auch da sind nicht alle digital
themen zu hause so wurde zum beispiel
der gaming bereich ausgegliedert und den
wirtschaftsministerium zugeordnet
das innenministerium ist zuständig für
die verwaltungs digitalisierung und
irgendwie mischt auch das
umweltministerium noch mit oft digital
politik aus einem guss müssen wir also
wohl noch ein paar jahre warten und was
ist mit den themen freiheit und
privatsphäre im internet der anschutz
wurde von der fdp in der letzten
legislaturperiode immer wieder gefordert
die abschaffung des netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz stand dabei für die
fdp immer ganz oben was wir von der afg
immer begrüßt haben das war allerdings
vor der regierungsübernahme
nachdem marco buschmann dann
justizminister geworden ist betonte in
aller welt einer seiner ersten
stellungnahme dass das nützt egi
verbindlich sei selbstverständlich auch
für viele klar gelte und er den
messenger-dienst strenger kontrollieren
wir frei nach dem motto was kümmert mich
mein geschwätz von gestern so schnell so
schnell wie sie von der fdp und kippen
kann man das wollte die bereit war nicht
mal aussprechen werte kollegen ob letzte
die impfpflicht schulden machen oder
zweig sie haben zu ihrem minister posten
nicht nur zentrale wahlversprechen
gebrochen sondern schlicht die freiheit
verraten meine damen und
und die bühnen die im letzten jahr vor
allem wenn digital ausschuss
öffentlichkeit verlangten lehnten diese
gestern ab und die spd nennt sie für das
erste äußerung zu digital politik weil
die sich zuerst um hass und hetze im
internet kümmern zu wollen also alles
beim alten beider neuen ampel meine
damen und herren und ausgerechnet ihnen
sollen wir jetzt das versprechen
abnehmen dass sie das mit der
digitalisierung ernst meinen noten
bekommen schön wär's aber mit verlaub da
glaube ich eher dem lebenslauf von frau
berger herzlichen dank
die kollegin dr jur verlinken hat das
wort für bündnis 90 die grünen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir wollen diese wahlperiode nutzen für
einen echten aufbruch in der
verkehrspolitik wie in vielen anderen
bereichen gibt es nach jahren des
bremsens und das verzögern sehr viel zu
tun es geht einmal um den beitrag des
verkehrssektors zum klimaschutz wir
haben uns als ampel das ziel gesetzt
wieder auf den 15 grad fahrt zu kommen
und dieses ziel erreichen wir nur
gemeinsam und wenn alle bereiche ein
beitrag leisten es geht aber auch um
modernisierung um digitalisierung um den
abbau von barrieren um passende angebote
für alle auch für diejenigen die keinen
führerschein haben oder die im rollstuhl
sitzen denn so unterschiedlich die
menschen sind so unterschiedlich sind
auch ihre bedürfnisse bei der mobilität
darauf haben sie hingewiesen herr
minister wir wollen deshalb eine
vielfalt an möglichkeiten schaffen vom
auto über den autonomen nahverkehrs bus
bis zum ic im halbstundentakt dazu
gehören ein lande und sichere radwege
abstellanlagen auch ein bahnhöfen um das
fahrrad und den öffentlichen verkehr
optimal zu verzahnen und dazu gehört
attraktives carsharing angebote digitale
lösung die das reisen und bezahlen
einfacher machen und die neuausrichtung
in der verkehrspolitik ist eine riesen
chance dass die menschen gut sicher und
bezahlbar mobil sein können und das ziel
ist das bessere mobilität nicht
automatisch zu mehr verkehr zu mehr lärm
und zu mehr flächenverbrauch führt und
ich bin zuversichtlich dass uns das in
der ampel gelingt also gemeinsam an
intelligenten und innovativen lösungen
arbeiten
[Applaus]
eine unserer verabredungen ist
anstehende infrastrukturvorhaben zu
überprüfen das ist notwendig und
vernünftig denn der letzte
bundesverkehrswegeplan der enthält
fehlen der straßenprojekte als jemals
gebaut werden können und die grundlagen
haben sich seit 2016 ja auch deutlich
verändert der verkehrsbereich hat seine
emissionen nicht senken können
gleichzeitig gibt es inzwischen ein
klimaschutzgesetz und den beschluss des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes das uns als
gesetzgeber auffordert mehr für den
klimaschutz zu tun und so die freiheiten
der kommenden generationen zu sichern
den großen handlungsbedarf sehen wir
auch in einem ganz aktuellen beispiels
wurde bereits genannt die
brückensperrung auf der sauerlandlinie
a45 und diese sperrung bis nur ein
vorbote von dem was uns in den kommenden
jahren erwartet denn bei der sanierung
von brücken und tunneln gibt es einen
riesigen rückstand
es ist ein skandal wie der unions
verkehrsminister und die unions
verkehrsminister die in den letzten
zwölf jahren die verantwortung für
unsere verkehrswege hatten jahrelang dem
verschleiß von straßen schienen und
brücken tatenlos zugesehen haben
ihnen haben wir das zu verdanken dass
wir jetzt in der viertgrößten
industrienationen autobahnen sperren
müssen weil die union lieber auf neue
straßen gesetzt hat anstatt die
bestehenden zu erhalten wir werden
wir werden als andere koalition einen
klaren fokus auf erhalt und sanierung
legen das schützt und auch vor weiteren
kosten fallen denn mit jeder neuen
bundesstraße erhöhen sich automatisch
auch die beträge die wir für die
instandhaltung zurücklegen müssen
gleichzeitig verringern sich
investitionsspielräume für die kommenden
regierungen große investition haben wir
im bereich schiene vor deren
marktanteile wollen wir deutlich
steigern sowohl im güter wie auch im
personenverkehr und ihr werden außerdem
mehr städte an den fernverkehr der bahn
anschließen und den deutschlandweiten
taktfahrplan auf der schiene
vorantreiben
und wir werden die
regionalisierungsmittel erhöhen wir
werden mit ländern und kommunen
standards für einen guten öffentlichen
nahverkehr festlegen das stärkt
ländliche regionen weil es die menschen
mehr wahlfreiheit bei der individuellen
mobilität gibt wir wollen die
lärmbelastung durch den verkehr
reduzieren stecken mehr geld in aktiven
und passiven lärmschutz an straßen und
schienen und all das gehen wir jetzt mit
der ampel an und darauf freue ich mich
herr minister vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner in der debatte ist
thomas lutze aus der linksfraktion hier
wird man schnell das pult desinfiziertes
wird zwischen leben redner gemacht und
dann kam er sprechen mitglied der
linksfraktion und im ausschuss für
verkehr
frau präsident sind sehr geehrte damen
und herren das positive vorweg und keine
angst es geht die schoko oder das
positive ist dass der neue
verkehrsminister einen riesigen vorteil
gegenüber seinen amtskollegen hat denn
schlechter als seine csu vorgänger kann
er es beim besten willen nicht machen
also lieber kollege wissen nutzen sie
diese fast einmalige chance und gehen
sie das projekt verkehrswende richtig an
ich glaube ihre beiden koalitionspartner
dort werden sie für so was sicherlich
unterstützung finden und auch meine
linksfraktion ist ihnen gerne behilflich
wenn es darum geht zum beispiel das
schienen letztendlich auszubauen
deutlich mehr güterverkehr von der
straße auf die schiene zu bekommen oder
die ländlichen räume so zu gestalten
dass niemand mehr sagen muss er oder sie
sei auf das auto angewiesen weil er
sonst nix pferd
und herr wissing
sie müssen wir müssen auch über das
gerät reden da kennt sich die ihre fdp
ja besonders gut aus denken sie doch
einfach mal die steuern so wie es auf
ihren plakaten steht weg mit der
mehrwertsteuer bei baan iv ticket das
wäre mal eine schlagzeile wir könnten
sie sich profilieren und millionen von
fahrgästen würden profitieren
und das thema sicherheit nur bei ihrer
elf dpa auch immer ganz groß geschrieben
na dann vorwärts weg mit der
weg mit nach vorwärts
tempolimit auf autobahnen erhöhen
nämlich die verkehrssicherheit eine
mehrheit in deutschland hat keinen bock
mehr auf diese weltweit einzigartige
raserei und selbst bei tempo 30 genau
geht es bei den konservativen voran in
meiner heimatstadt saarbrücken führt
jetzt revision sie genau dazu eine
mehrheit aus cdu grünen und fdp ein
tempolimit von 30 km h in der innenstadt
ein machen sie das doch bitte auch mit
ihrer bundesregierung unsere
unterstützung dafür haben sie herzlich
auf
[Applaus]
hier und jetzt die erste rede von
maximilian von kaiserstuhl die objekte
funke kaiser ist die die tarifpolitische
sprecher seiner fraktion ist
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter bundesminister die wir
kolleginnen und kollegen wir beginnen
mit der ampel koalition eine neue
zeitrechnung denn
statt all das was wir die letzten jahre
verschlafen haben all die möglichkeiten
die wir verpasst haben der fortschritt
der zunichte gemacht wurde all das
packen wir es endlich an und das neue
bundesministerium für digitales und
verkehr ist der beweis dieses
gestaltungswillens liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
dann statt wie bisher die digital
politik als zahnlosen tiger im
bundeskanzleramt ja geradezu krepieren
zu lassen haben die kompetenzen endlich
mal in einem bundesministerium gebündelt
und zwar im bundesministerium für
digitales und verkehr das gab es in
dieser form noch nie das ist ein
absoluter meilenstein
wir werden hier werden die
digitalisierung auf jeden fall nicht
mehr als schaufensterpolitik
missbrauchen sondern endlich die
politischen weichen für die voll
umfassenden überfällige digitalisierung
in diesem land ebnen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das möchte ich an zwei
themen beispielhaft festmacht zum einen
an der digitalen infrastruktur schnelles
internet sei es mobilfunk oder breitband
das ist ein grundbedürfnis und ich finde
es traurig dass wir im jahre 2022 das
immer noch so betonen müssen massive
bürokratische schwächen haben hier den
ausbau bislang verschleppt was wir unter
anderen ändern werde wir verschlanken
und digitalisieren
antrags und genehmigungsverfahren
wir finalisieren die normierung
alternativer verleger techniken und wir
stärken das monitoring damit kommunen
und ausbauen unternehmen überhaupt
wissen wo was liegt wir wollen
schlichtweg vom funkloch zum highspeed
weltmeister werden und uns an dieser
stelle deutlich zu sagen nichts anderes
ist einem industriestaat wie deutschland
würde ich liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
zweitens werden wir das thema digitale
identitäten an nachdem die id wolle der
ein oder andere wird sich noch daran
erinnern im vergangenen jahr unter
führung des bundeskanzleramtes krachend
an die wand gefahren worden ist die
sichere digitale identifizierung die es
nicht nur ein grundpfeiler der
digitalisierung unseres landes sie hätte
und das ist traurig sie hätte uns auch
bei der bekämpfung der korona pandemie
geholfen zusammen mit einem antrag losen
und automatisieren automatisierten
verfahren in den behörden und trug bei
der verbesserung und umsetzung des
online zugangs gesetzes auch aus dem bm
dvr ausmachen wir unseren staat
einfacher und schneller denn wir
brauchen einen unkomplizierten start der
zum einen die bürgerinnen und bürger das
leben erleichtert und eben auch in
krisenzeiten handlungsfähig bleibt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
was mir wichtig ist wir wollen es nicht
nur besser wissen wir werden es auch
besser machen und ich bin dankbar dafür
dass ich als digital politischer
sprecher der fdp-fraktion hierbei das
erbe von jimmy schulz weiter tragen darf
ich freue mich auf die zukünftige
zusammenarbeit mit ihm hier im hohen
haus und ich freue mich natürlich auch
auf die zusammenarbeit mit den kollegen
kollegen im bundesministerium vorneweg
doktor volker wissing damit wir zeigen
können dass deutschland zu deutlich mehr
imstande ist wenn es um die
digitalisierung in deutschland gibt
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
für die cdu csu fraktion hat jetzt das
wort der kollege ulrich lange
autoschlangen ist stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der linken im
deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrter herr
bundesminister
viele schöne schlagworte viele
ankündigungen und inzwischen einmal die
rednerinnen und redner der neuen
koalition und wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin
ich habe noch nicht so richtig erkennen
können ob alle vom gleichen haus und vom
gleichen
koalitionsvertrag und vom gleichen
ministerium gesprochen haben zum einen
haben wir festgestellt im
koalitionsvertrag
65 mal das wort investitionen aber nur
drei mal das wort milliarde wo es
herkommen soll bleiben große
fragezeichen
und was ich jetzt schon gezeigt hat der
fehlende mut der fehlende mut liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen denn
es ist viel rein geschrieben aber nicht
klar benannt weil wohl unbezahlbar und
vieles genannt aber nicht konkret weil
man sich wohl nicht einigen konnte und
deswegen hat man es zunächst mal groß
verpackt und ich sage ihnen jetzt eines
der hier von großem neuen zeitalter von
respekt und von vielen anderen spricht
gerade verkehrspolitiker wissen dass
wenn das geld nicht da ist ist
ungedeckte schecks sind und das macht
mir sorge
und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
infrastruktur braucht konstanz und
planbarkeit und minister ich garantiere
ihnen heute schon den trick mit der
wirklichkeit bei all dem was hier
genannt wurde und ich warne und wir
warnen vor
milliardenschweren verschiebe bahnhöfen
im haushalt des verkehrsministeriums
und wenn sie respekt einfordern dann
fordern auch wir respekt ein denn das
mehrausgaben für viele im haushalt drin
sind das war die alte bundesregierung
und kein verdienst der neuen
und das bekenntnis zur straße hätte
ihnen auch gut getan und ein neuer
bundesverkehrswegeplan wie es da gerade
gehört habe mit einem dialog prozess da
spielen natürlich in den ländlichen
räumen die alarmglocken wollen sie die
ländlichen räume abhängen wollen sie
wollen sie das auto zurückbringen das
sage ich ihnen ganz deutlich das wird
nicht funktionieren denn auch das wird
derzeit mit der wirklichkeit werden
statt in berlin zu diskutieren muss man
in der infrastruktur sich auf planung
und kosten verlassen und dort weiter
bauen wo man begonnen hat bei der
schiene fehlt ihnen der mut und wissen
sie warum haben sie hier die alte
dampflok spd sitzen dann haben sie frau
kollegin gerade vom
halbstundentakt bei ece gesprochen wir
helfen ihnen gerne das system bahn zu
verstehen der fernverkehr ist
eigenwirtschaftlich und zum deutschland
takt habe ich heute nichts gehört auch
da fehlt viel und lieber kollege müller
ganz offen das war schwach wir haben uns
gut verstanden das war schwach zwölf der
16 jahre war die spd mit dabei noch nie
wurde so viel investiert wie unter
unions-geführten
bundesverkehrsminister noch nie so viel
für den ländlichen raum noch nie so viel
für die viele noch nie so viel in der
straßeninfrastruktur
gerichtet noch nie so viel für radwege
und noch nie so viel wird für saubere
luft liebe neue koalition daran werden
sie sich messen lassen müssen sie
brauchen eine verkehrspolitik mit
augenmaß das heiße kohlen rad und auto
das reisen nicht verbieten verteuern
oder vermiesen wir bieten konstruktive
opposition an für mobilität in ganz
deutschland für alle bürger
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
der immer betont investiert wurde das
ist tatsächlich schon immer schon immer
so gewesen wie schon häufig so gewesen
dass das verkehrsministerium das
ministerium war mit dem größten
investitionshaushalt dennoch ist
natürlich viel zu tun unter anderem muss
oder soll die verwaltung digitalisierte
werden wenn wir spricht dazu nun auch
der digital politische sprecher der spd
fraktion jens zimmermann
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen lieber kollege
lange man merkt in diesen tagen so
richtig die union leicht nach einer
langen periode der opposition so richtig
mal wieder was umsetzen zu können
nach 16 jahren aber ich glaube das wird
zumindest noch ein bisschen dauern von
dem was sie hier heute so erzählt haben
denn wenn ich mal zurückdenke 16 jahre
das waren schon mal eine lange ära unter
helmut kohl und als 1998 hier dann eine
regierungserklärung abgegeben wurde hieß
es wir wollen nicht alles anders aber
vieles besser machen und heute muss man
aber sagen wir wollen es nicht nur
besser machen sondern wir müssen
tatsächlich auch vieles anders machen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
darin sind wir uns in dieser koalition
einig und dafür haben wir ideen konkrete
pläne und ja ambitionierte pläne in
diesem koalitionsvertrag gesteckt wir
wollen mehr fortschritt waren dazu
gehört für uns eben auch ein digitaler
aufbruch unserer gesellschaft bei der
infrastruktur aber eben auch beim
menschenbild und bei den bürgerrechten
und beides ist zentral um unser land und
europa für die zukunft aufzustellen und
wir wollen eben ein solidarisches und
flächendeckendes und eine konsequente
digitalisierung und wenn ich sage wir
müssen etwas anders machen dann betrifft
das auch die zusammenarbeit in dieser
koalition wir wollen als ampel diese
ziele nicht jeder für sich nicht
gegeneinander sondern gemeinsam
erreichen und das unterscheidet diese
koalition ganz massiv von der der
letzten acht jahre meine damen und
herren
es ist ganz klar ein digitaler aufbruch
der bedeutet eben auch dass wir unsere
hausaufgaben machen müssen das ist
vollkommen klar die haben wir aus den
vergangenen jahren mitgenommen wir
brauchen einen schnellen
infrastrukturausbau wir brauchen mehr
investitionen in digitale bildung und
wir brauchen eine digitale und
zeitgemäße verwaltung und was uns als
sozialdemokratinnen sozialdemokraten
besonders wichtig ist wir müssen den
bürgerinnen und bürger sicherheit in
diesem digitalen wandel bieten denn für
viele ist digitalisierung nicht nur
chance nicht nur verheißung sondern
bringt eben auch viele sorgen mit und
unsere aufgabe ist es hier sicherheit zu
bieten meine damen und herren
und neben all diesen harten fakten der
digitalisierung geht es eben auch um die
bürgerrechte und diese koalition hat
eben auch in ihrem vertrag ein anderes
menschenbild der ganzen geschichte
zugrunde gelegt und deswegen haben wir
uns ist ein sperriges wort gibt viele
punkte beim scrabble auf eine
überwachungs gesamtrechnung geeinigt
eine inventur der sicherheitsgesetze in
unserem land denn wir wollen sicherheit
und freiheit wieder in die richtige
balance bringen meine damen und herren
und deshalb freue ich mich auch auf die
zusammenarbeit mit unserer
bundesinnenministerium mit nancy faeser
die in den ersten wochen schon klare
kante gezeigt hat gerade gegen rechten
hass im internet und meine damen und
herren ich freue mich natürlich auch auf
die zusammenarbeit mit unserem neuen
minister mit volker wissing und auf die
zusammenarbeit innerhalb der koalition
aber das will ich zum abschluss auch
explizit betont ich freue mich auch auf
den konstruktiven austausch und auch auf
den konstruktiven streit mit union und
den kolleginnen kollegen von den linken
herzlichen dank
für die afg spricht doch durch spanien
pick spanier sprecher für verkehr und
digitale infrastruktur seine fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren dass sie mich
zunächst einige persönliche worte sagen
ich bin nach meiner corona erkrankung
seit 23 tagen gesund ich bin negativ
getestet und trotzdem werde ich aus dem
parlament auf die besuchertribüne
gehoben verband in fünf tagen darf ich
zusammen mit den vielen nicht getesteten
wieder unten im plenum sitzen und diese
fakten sagen mehr über politische
entscheidungswege im deutschen bundestag
als irgendwelche sachdiskussion
lassen sonst lassen uns so
verkehrspolitiker
zwischen der fdp und der afg gab es in
der vergangenen wahlperiode eine
beachtliche verkehrspolitische
übereinstimmung bei immerhin 27 von 40
fdp anträgen haben wir zugestimmt und
insbesondere im bereich
infrastruktur erneuerung waren wir uns
in der vergangenheit zumindest in vielen
punkten weitgehend einig jetzt kommt es
zur nagelprobe das drama um die
plötzlich und unerwartet
marode autobahnbrücke damit ist
sinnbildlich für die
realitätsverweigerung der bisherigen
infrastrukturplanung im verkehrssektor
und mich schockiert in diesem
zusammenhang dass es im
verkehrsministerium
offensichtlich keinen standard plan gibt
für renovierung und neubau insbesondere
von brücken vorhaben er wissen sie
treten ein schweres erbe an muss man
leider so sagen das nächste große thema
ist die immer unbezahlbare mobil und
bezahlbare mobilität
für die menschen in diesem land und das
lösen sie nicht mit stark
subventionierten tickets für den öpnv
weil der in weiten teilen unseres landes
ist überhaupt gar keine rolle spielt das
problem der menschen in diesem land das
ist der liter benzin der im moment bei
circa 1 eur 70 liegt schade dass der
kanzler nicht da ist immer gut wenn er
auch mal den spritpreis höher es gibt es
gibt ja stimmen die sagen der hohe
spritpreis liegt an den rohölpreisen der
barrel rohöl kostet kostet ungefähr 80
dollar zwischen 2011 und 2012 lager im
jahresmittel bei 110 dollar die
endkundenpreise einer tankstelle sind
heute trotzdem höher also wir wollen die
irgendwas erzählen dass es an den
rohölpreisen liegt es sind die
politischen maßnahmen in diesem land wie
die co2 steuer wie autofahren und
übrigens auch den öpnv immer teurer
machen und wenn ich den
und und wenn ich den koalitionsvertrag
lese dann kann ich ihr konzept nicht
erkennen er wissen wie sie mit dem nach
wie vor hohen mobilitäts wunsch der
bürger hier in diesem land wie sie dem
nahe kommen wollen und den erfüllen
wollen ganz im gegenteil ich lese dort
formulierung die sehr deutlich darauf
hindeuten dass sie die menschen in
diesem land umziehen wollen hin zu
weniger mobilität und das hört sich für
mich völlig anders an als das was sie
die letzte wahlperiode versprochen haben
aber er wissen wir wollen sie an ihren
taten messen und wir hoffen dass nicht
das gleiche passiert wie hier mit den
vertretern der
gegner der impfpflicht wir hoffen dass
sie wenigstens ihr wort halten und im
fraglichen tor nicht umfallen vielen
dank
war das für die fdp-fraktion weil das
angesprochen möchte ich noch einmal
etwas lehren im plenarsaal gilt jetzt
zweig plus also die abgeordneten im
plenarsaal möchten müssen damit geimpft
oder gewesen plus geimpft sein und noch
einen aktuellen test vorweisen sonst
sitzen sie eben auf der tribüne
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen wo
werden wir wollen wir stehen im jahr
2025 die drei punkte herausgreifen wir
müssen die klimaschutzziele im verkehr
erreicht haben zweitens wir brauchen
mobilität für alle in der stadt genauso
wie auf dem land und dafür eine
funktionierende infrastruktur und
drittens mobilität muss endlich sicher
sein das sind die vereinbarten ziele
auch des koalitionsvertrages und da gilt
es jetzt zu fragen wo stehen wir
eigentlich und das ist glaube ich für
herrn bereichs besonders wichtig aber am
letzten ausschuss ja nicht dabei
deswegen vielleicht mit schreiben die
ziele sachen elektromobilität sind
massiv verfehlt worden bei rad- und
fußverkehr wurde vor allem papier
geschwärzt marode straßen und brücken
füllen die zeitung die ziele die in
sachen verkehrssicherheit die
bundesregierung selbst sich gesteckt
hatte sind allesamt verfehlt worden das
ist die bilanz der letzten regierung und
da muss sich einiges ändern
die werden wir also sichere
klimafreundliche mobilität für alle
erreichen vieles muss dafür gleichzeitig
angegangen werden beginnen wir bei der
sicherheit im koalitionsvertrag ist die
vision zero für weniger unfälle und mehr
verkehrssicherheit verankert ich begrüße
den vorstoß zu tempo 30 zu mehr tempo 30
minister wissing das wird ein wichtiger
schritt und ich finde aus der vision
zero muss eine mission zero werden und
dafür stehen wir bereit
nächster punkt mobilität für alle setzt
eine funktionierende infrastruktur
voraus und daher werden wir die mittel
erhöhen ebenso wie für den nahverkehr
der nationalen radverkehrsplan wird
umgesetzt werden insbesondere das
radnetz ist auszubauen wir haben uns
dazu verständigen welche infrastruktur
hier künftig brauchen und dazu haben wir
was neues auch im koalitionsvertrag
verankert mich einen sogenannten
gleichstellungs scheck und der
sicherheit erstmals den einfluss der
verschiedensten perspektiven zb von
jungen von alt das ist neu und das ist
gut wir kümmern uns auch
um die straßen infrastrukturen und dass
das bitter nötig ist das sagen immer
wieder landauf landab alle fraktionen
dass er betont aber
herr bereits von der vorgängerregierung
eben nicht einfach nicht gemacht und das
muss jetzt anders werden ich habe kurz
überlegt
ich habe kurz überlegt ob man die a45
baustelle des herrn bareiß widmet aber
ich finde nach diesem flammenden
plädoyer für die schweizer
verkehrspolitik gehört diese baustelle
ganz eindeutig ihnen herr lange 40 ist
ganz eindeutig
künftig dürftig hat der vorgang erhalt
vor dem neubau die 49 die vielen straßen
neubauprojekte die werden überprüft
werden müssen das ist auch logisch und
das ist auch konsequent die
klimaschutzziele dass die gelten auch
ganz klar im verkehr und da muss ich
mich auch gedanken das hat der herr
verkehrsminister heute mal ganz explizit
klar formulierten das gut so deswegen
werden wir statt verbrennen elektroautos
auf den markt bringen deswegen wird es
ein klima check geben das ist übrigens
der realität stegherr lange und deswegen
werden dann damit auch gesetzt maßnahmen
transparent und steuerbar in ihren
auswirkungen auf klima werden es geht
enorm viel aufzuholen und mit dieser
neuen koalition wird daher sich vieles
bewegen müssen mobilität kann sicher
kann nachhaltig kann erschwinglich sein
das ist keine utopie das ist handwerk
und dafür laden wir alle auch in gute
zusammenarbeit ein vielen dank
[Applaus]
die nächste rednerin sehen wir hier
schon im bild anke domscheit-berg für
die linksfraktion und sie sitzt im
ausschuss für die therme ist
sehr geehrte präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen es ist ganz egal welches
ranking man sich zur digitalisierung an
guckt man kann ziemlich sicher sein
deutschland ist irgendwo ganz weit unten
die ampelkoalition hat viele dinge
versprochen wie sie das verändern will
schöne versprechen hat die gruppe auch
schon gemacht und wir haben inzwischen
alle gelernt bei digitalisierung kommt
es vor allem darauf an wie schafft man
die umsetzung und ob die klappt das
hängt vor allem von zwei faktoren ab zum
einen gibt es eine gute
digitalisierungsstrategie zum anderen
gibt es eine kluge und effektive
governance eine zuordnung von rollen und
verantwortungen eine
digitalisierungsstrategie gibt es noch
nicht die muss natürlich zeitnah
prioritär entwickelt werden sie muss
sehr eng verbunden sein mit der
nachhaltigkeitsstrategie diese beiden
themen haben unfassbar viel miteinander
zu tun sie muss aber auch sinnvolle
messbare und verbindliche ziele
enthalten also nicht so was die früher
bei der große anzahl elektronischer
dienstleistungen der öffentlichen
verwaltung sondern was man messen muss
ist wie viele bürger innen nutzen diese
dienste und wie zufrieden sind sie damit
die strategie muss aber auch die
kompetenzdefizite adressieren ohne eine
flächendeckende weiterbildungsoffensive
in der digitalen verwaltung sind
fortschritte in der digitalisierung
nicht erreichbar
zum zweiten
die verteilung der verantwortungen
rollen usw
überzeugen mich in der ampelkoalition
ehrlich gesagt noch nicht und erst recht
nicht nach der rede des ministers ich
frage mich aber auch beim hat kanzler
scholz alle im kanzleramt bisher
angesiedelten aufgaben zur
digitalisierung fallengelassen die heiße
kartoffeln
digitalisierungsstrategie muss chefsache
sein und das war wirklich ein falsches
signal
die damen und herren der ampel koalition
in der letzten legislatur habe ich 40
mal am ende meiner reden die abschaffung
des § 209 10 a gefordert bitte setzen
sie auch dieses versprechen
schnellstmöglich um bei zwei minuten
redezeit brauche ich jeden satz für
digitales vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin in dieser debatte ist
dorothee martin für die spd
verkehrspolitische sprecherin
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren eine fortschrittliche
politik das ist das was spd grüne und
fdp 1 und dieser mut und wille zum
fortschritt wird auch die neue
verkehrspolitik dieser ampel koalition
prägen nicht weniger als das ist auch
nötig denn wir stehen auch im
verkehrsbereich vor wirklich großen
herausforderungen mobilität bleibt ein
wesentlicher faktor für klimaschutz für
teilhabe und auch für unser
erfolgreiches industrieland
wir wollen das haben meine vorgängerin
vorher schon gesagt wir wollen mobilität
fortschrittlicher und nachhaltige
gestalten zukunftsfest machen das gilt
für die schiene für häfen für
schifffahrt für den luftverkehr und auch
weiterhin für die straße dass wir im
verkehrsbereich vor einer vor einem
enormen
transformationsprozess stehen das sollte
wirklich jeden in diesem hause klar sein
und
diesen hohen und um diesen hohen
anforderungen von nachhaltigkeit von
klimaschutz von infrastruktur jetzt
wirklich gerecht zu werden brauchen wir
einfach deutlich mehr tempo im
politischen prozess in der planung und
eine umsetzung was wir wirklich nicht
weiter brauchen das sind bremsklötze von
cdu csu wir brauchen keine weiteren
verhinderer und wir brauchen vor allem
kein verantwortungsloses maut disaster
mehr meine damen und herren
mein kollege richard müller hat schon
unsere besondere bedeutung und den fokus
von bahn und china hervorgehoben und ich
möchte noch einen weiteren fokus setzen
ich bin auch ein minister wissen sehr
dankbar für seine klaren worte nämlich
elektromobilität hier setzen wir ganz
neu an wöchentlich werden derzeit etwa
250 neue ladepunkte in deutschland
gebaut damit aber im jahr 2030 15
millionen e autos auf unseren straßen
unterwegs sein können müssen s2000
ladepunkte pro woche sein unser ziel als
ampelkoalition ist klar wir werden eine
million öffentlich zugängliche
ladepunkte bis 20.30 schaffen und damit
deutlich mehr anreize auf
elektromobilität umzusteigen
wir werden dabei sicherstellen dass die
strompreise eine ladung sollen
transparenz sind dass man gezielt ohne
langes suchen freie ladesäulen finden
kann und das flächendeckend e mobilität
wird künftig überall selbstverständlich
und einfach nutzbar sein und sie wird
zusammen mit digitalisierung im
verkehrsbereich die mobilität ganz
gravierend verändern sie
klimafreundlicher sicherer komfortabler
und einfacher machen gleiches gilt auch
für den bereich pkw für ein
verlässliches ladesäulen netz was wir
brauchen und auch für wasserstoff als
wichtige antriebsform gerade im bereich
lkw
das alles bedeutet aber auch für die
automobilindustrie einen ganz großen und
einen notwendigen
transformationsprozess denen je nach
kräften unterstützen werden denn sie ist
eine unserer schlüsselindustrien und wir
wollen dass das so bleibt künftig
daneben mit e-mobilität aus antriebsart
der zukunft so sichern wir arbeitsplätze
so schaffen wir neue und darauf können
sich die beschäftigten und die
unternehmen verlassen damen und herren
liebe
kolleginnen kollegen ich komme aus
hamburg dort gibt es eine vielzahl an
wirklich guten und verletzten
mobilitätsangeboten aber auch im
ländlichen raum in kleinstädten muss
mobilität möglich sein und bleiben
niemand darf abgehängt werden weil er
sich mobilität nicht mehr leisten kann
oder weil angebote noch fehlen und für
uns steht ganz klar fest der umbau
unserer verkehrsinfrastruktur der wird
nur funktionieren wenn wir stadt und
land gleichermaßen einbinden und wenn
wir mobilitätsangebote auch an
lebensrealitäten abbilden auch das ist
übrigens eine frage des respekts liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir wollen eine vernetzung von
individual- und öffentlichem verkehr und
kein gegeneinander der mobilität richtet
sich für uns an den verschiedenen
bedürfnissen alle aus egal ob zu fuß rad
oder auto wir werden hier ein neues
miteinander schaffen in der mobilität
sicher
klimafreundlich und innovation soffin
freue mich auf die zusammenarbeit in der
koalition ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit mit ihnen herr minister
wissen dass uns anpacken vielen dank
[Applaus]
hierzu verkehrs ausgebaut zum schluss
der koalitionsvertrag ist bei diesem
thema doch
stellenweise rechte vage von daher wird
sich erst zeigen wie die ampel
parteien das umsetzen wollen unter
anderem um emissionen in diesem sektor
zu senken nadine schön ist die nächste
rednerin stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der unionsfraktion
hier im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
das waren ja blumige worte des neuen
digital ministers in puncto
digitalisierung aber leider keine
einzige konkrete aussage
wo sollte digitalisierungs politik
unseres landes hingehen wo sehen sie
unser land 20 30 was heißt der digitale
aufbruch in deutschland und europa wie
wollen sie transformationen erreichen
wie wollen sie die chancen der
digitalisierung nutzen davon habe ich in
ihrer rede minister leider nichts gehört
blumige worte keine konkreten maßnahmen
und all das was schief fdp in den
letzten vier jahren hier in jeder
debatte gesagt hat finde ich nichts
davon nicht im koalitionsvertrag
nicht in den ersten verlautbarungen der
bundesregierung und auch nicht in der
rede des ministers vier jahre hat kann
sie gesagt ist auch mehr monitoring es
braucht mehr steuerung und es braucht
ein digital ministerium und was machen
sie sie waren weniger monitoring weniger
steuerung und auch kein digital
ministerium es reicht nicht den namen
eines haus zu ändern und digitales vorne
hin zu schreiben man muss dann auch
wirklich digital kompetenzen bündeln man
bis budgets bunten man muss steuern
monitoren und das ganze mit kennzahlen
versehen und nichts davon findet man in
ihrer realität
nicht beim thema infrastruktur wer sich
den koalitionsvertrag durchliest ließ
dort ftth in jedem haus dass es ein
schönes ziel aber niemand dort hinkommen
will wann man dort hinkommen will wie
man das ganze monitoren will nichts
davon zu lesen das thema digitale
transformation des staates ist das erste
kapitel in ihrem koalitionsvertrag das
war das erste kapitel in die irre
sanierungs papier und ich dachte ja
genau das ist genau das richtige thema
im koalitionsvertrag findet man da auch
relativ viel konkrete sachen das eine
oder andere kam er auch bekannt voraus
und seinen alten papieren aber wer soll
das eigentlich machen macht das
halbwissen als neue digital ministerium
der normenkontrollrat ist gerade vom
kanzleramt gewandert zum
bundesjustizministerium zuhören
buschmann für die digitale verwaltung
ist nancy faeser zuständig hat wissing
hat wohl auch teile davon der strategie
aus dem bundeskanzleramt bekommen das
vor zeitmanagement ich bei frau stark
watzinger wie bitte soll digitale
transformation des staates passieren
wenn sie so eine zerfledderte und
zerklüftete landschaft haben und das was
das kanzleramt bisher in koordinierung
gemacht haben haben sie auch gleich noch
gestritten
ich lasse mich sehr gerne positiv
überraschen denn unser land braucht eine
digitale transformation des staates es
braucht auch das was sie gesagt haben
die digitalisierung der mobilität aber
auch hier für smart cities ist das
bauministerium zuständig und wir
wünschen ihnen sehr viel wir wünschen
ihnen sehr viel glück dabei aber mit so
wenig koordinierung mit so wenig
monitoring mit so wenig konkreten
maßnahmen wird es nicht gelingen sie
haben die chance das ganze zu
konkretisiert und wir sind an ihrer
seite wir wollen sie bei dieser
transformation unterstützen aber weder
der koalitionsvertrag und schon garnicht
geräten des heutigen tages lasse mich da
irgendwie optimistisch sein
nimmt eine frau kollegin
sollte sie gar nicht so anders als zu
ende was ich habe noch 1 minute und wird
das auch ganz gerne noch weiter
lieber minister liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
sie finden in unseren positionspapieren
uns in unserer politik viele
ansatzpunkte wie wir das wirklich
gemeinsam schaffen wollen und ich will
ihnen heute die hand ausstrecken das
auch gemeinsam zu tun dafür müssen sie
aber fragen beantworten wäre die
zuständigkeiten wäre die budgets wer
koordiniert wehrmacht die strategie und
dann können wir gemeinsam die digitale
transformation von stadtverwaltung und
auch von unserer wirtschaft schaffen ich
würde mich freuen wenn es gelingt unser
land kann sich keine verlorenen jahre
leisten
vielen dank jetzt sind sie gekommen
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin eckers
ski ist mit der fraktion zu ihrer ersten
mal mit
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen der
demokratischen fraktionen sehr geehrte
damen und herren
früher haben wir ab und an mal einen
brief geschrieben und tagelang auf
antwort gewartet heute verschicken und
empfangen wir täglich dutzende
nachrichten ob dienstlich oder privat ob
e-mail foto- oder sprachnachricht durch
dieses meer und dieser art an
kommunikation ist die vertraulichkeit
wichtiger denn je sie ist durch die
technische entwicklung aber auch stärker
gefährdet als jemals zuvor
werden wir uns bei der briefpost auf den
umschlag und die post als
dienstleisterin verlassen konnten sind
unsere daten im internet nur die starke
verschlüsselung von neugierigen mit
leser innen geschützt und um diese daten
zu schützen ist das recht auf
verschlüsselung unabdingbar mit starker
kryptographie ohne hintertüren und
kompromisse dieses geld wollen wir als
fortschritt koalition einführen
wir brauchen nicht nur sichere
verschlüsselung sondern auch sichere
hard und software deswegen wollen wir
zusätzlich eine hersteller und haftung
für schäden auf den weg bringen die
durch fahrlässig oder vorsätzlich
verursachte it sicherheits lücken
entstehen die verantwortung von
unternehmen sichere produkte anzubieten
wird in zukunft nicht mehr an der kasse
enden
woraus besteht aber die software dieser
produkte viele hersteller in nutzen open
source projekte also software die auf
den ehrenamtliche arbeit her und
öffentlich zur verfügung gestellt wird
aktuell gibt es die debatte im look von
open source komponenten den über 5000
produkten verwendet wurde und eine bis
letzten dezember unbekannte
sicherheitslücke beinhaltet hatte durch
diese lücke konnten angreiferinnen code
auf betroffenen systemen ausführen und
es dadurch übernehmen diese komponente
haben zwei programmierer nach feierabend
betreut zwei programmierer nach
feierabend das ist doch kein zustand
meine damen und herren es
geht hierbei um die sicherheit von uns
allen im netz während also produkte die
auf open source software basieren
oftmals millionen erwirtschaften so
findet die entwicklung selbst immens
wichtige open source komponenten viel zu
oft als personell und finanziell
schlecht ausgestattet das
freizeitprojekt engagierter
programmierer innenstadt vielen dank an
der stelle an die programmierer in aber
das darf nicht die norm sein sondern
muss ordentlich gefördert werden
open-source-software kann gerade wegen
des offenen codes von unabhängigen
sicherheitsexperten den jederzeit auf
ihre sicherheit überprüft werden das
schafft transparenz und vertrauen und
mit der verpflichtung sicherheitslücken
zu schließen schützen wir unsere systeme
und uns alle was tun wir also in die
aktuelle situation zu verbessern
wir führen ein recht auf verschlüsselung
und die hersteller in haftung bei die
sicherheitslücken ein und zusätzlich
wollen wir dass hard- und software in
die öffentliche gelder fließt und wo dem
keine zwingenden gründe entgegenstehen
auch als open source projekt der
allgemeinheit zugänglich gemacht werden
das motto heißt hier public money public
ich bin mir sicher gemeinsam schaffen
wir es deutschland auf europäischer und
internationaler ebene zu einem
leuchtturm für sichere
informationstechnologie zu machen
herzlichen dank
songs wie
rainer restaurant steht schon bereit
digital politischer sprecher der
unionsfraktion im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
herr präsident fährt der kolleginnen und
kollegen die köpfe und die rede meiner
vorgängerin nadine schön wir haben wir
versucht nachzuvollziehen wer in der
neuen rot grün gelben koalition
eigentlich welche zuständigkeiten für
digitalisierung bekommen hat und die
schicks vorweg es ist kompliziert
deswegen war ein bild gemalt
um sozusagen die verschiedenen
kompetenzverschiebungen bei zu
visualisieren und man erkennt eines jede
farbe kompass und jede farbe gibt was
ich gibt einen entsprechenden falls die
kollegen der ampelkoalition interesse an
der grafik haben um sie selber kennen zu
lernen ich gebe sie nachher gerne weiter
was übrigens auch der grafik fehlt
kollegen von der fdp ist dieser große
gelbe kasten denen sie im wahlkampf
versprochen haben das bundesministerium
für digitale transformation das gibt es
nicht das war eine gute idee
herausgekommen ist ein
etikettenschwindel
das bundesministerium für dieses
digitales und verkehr ist für vieles
zuständig aber eben für viele digitale
themen nicht
aber jetzt möchte ich die regierung ja
gar nicht daran messen in die weiten des
fdp-wahlprogramm umsetzt aber ich messe
daran inwieweit die ausstellung die sie
gewählt haben geeignet ist um die
zentralen herausforderungen in der
digitalen welt unseres jahrzehnts zu
lösen und nach dieser woche bin ich
ehrlich gesagt etwas skeptisch und ich
will das auch begründen jetzt fast alle
debatten aller minister verfolgt und wir
haben in europa im moment drei große
weichenstellungen die in den nächsten
monaten erfolgen werden und die unseren
digitalen raum in europa für die
nächsten für das nächste jahrzehnt mit
prägen werden das ist der digital market
act der die marktmacht von google
facebook und amazon begrenzen soll das
ist der digital services act der unter
anderem den umgang mit illegalen
inhalten im netz regeln sollen und das
ist die eu verordnung für künstliche
intelligenz dieses vertrauen der
menschen in diese technik stärken sollen
alles drei zentrale fragen die jeden
bürger in europa betreffen die jedes
unternehmen in europa betreffen und die
da über die zukunftsfähigkeit und die
innovationsfähigkeit unseres
europäischen digitalen marktes in europa
mit entscheiden die position der
bundesregierung in dieser woche dazu
0 in keiner debatte hat es in
irgendeiner form eine rolle spielt der
zuständige superminister robert habeck
in dessen verantwortungsbereich es fehlt
redet lieber und natürlich ums klima das
ist ein kerngeschäft der
digitalisierung minister ist nicht
zuständig ich könnte das gleiche bild
bei dem thema verwaltungsmodernisierung
zeichnen eine der zentralen
herausforderung und die
erwartungshaltung auch der bürger dass
sie ihr auto nicht nur mit dem handy
kaufen können sondern dass diese auch
digital zu lassen können und sich nicht
mit halben tag urlaub nehmen müssen um
dann im landratsamt nummer zu ziehen und
sie haben stuhl zu setzungen zu warten
bis sie dran sind die zuständige
innenministerin
hat lange über den kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus gesprochen das ist
richtig und wichtig aber wir brauchen
auch jemanden der sich um die digitale
verwaltung die wahl
verwaltungsmodernisierung kümmert
und das problem an diesem bild er ehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen von der ampel
jeder hat sich ein paar interessante
themen gekrallt jeder kann gut
förderbescheide übergeben aber jeder hat
neben seinen kern gehen aber jeder hat
ein anderes kerngeschäft und um die
fragen der digitalisierung wird sich
übergreifend zu wenig zentral gekümmert
und das wird der großen aufgabe die vor
uns steht nicht gerecht und da kamen sie
jetzt genügend zeit und raum noch besser
zu werden herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
die kommen damit zum vorletzten redner
in dieser debatte zum ministerium für
digitales und verkehr beste der
legislatur noch das ministerium für
verkehr und digitales
außendorf spricht nun digital
politischer sprecher von bündnis 90 die
grünen im deutschen größten
der präsident sehr geehrte damen und
herren sehr geehrter herr minister
wissing digitalisierung ist neben dem
klimaschutz das große thema unserer zeit
auch hier liegen probleme und lösungen
dicht beieinander und ich möchte zuerst
ein problem ansprechen bevor ich frau
hören dann zu den chancen komme und das
ist der energieverbrauch in
rechenzentren endgeräten und
übertragungsnetzen die internetnutzung
in deutschland erzeugt etwa so viel co2
emissionen wieder flugverkehr dieses
problem adressieren wir in unserem
koalitionsvertrag mit einem umwelt
management vorbildhaft lich für die
rechnung des bundes ab 2025 und der
verpflichtenden klimaneutralität für
neue rechenzentren ab 2027 auch auch an
dieser stelle zeigt sich wie wichtig der
beschleunigte ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien ist auf dieser problemlage
heraus haben sich aber auch
zukunftsweisende lösungen entwickelt zb
die nutzung von abwärme aus
rechenzentren für die nach einer
versorgung oder wie ein beispiel aus
nordfriesland zeigt dort wurde ein
gewächshaus auf ein rechenzentrum gebaut
damit geheizt und das ist unterm strich
dann sogar klima positiv
es geht noch weiter viele große
rechenzentren haben eigene batterie
speicher um stromausfälle überbrücken zu
können und eben diese speicher die
können als puffer dienen um das netz zu
stabilisieren und somit selbst einen
beitrag zur energiewende leisten
und so liegt das in der dna von
informatikerinnen probleme als
herausforderung zu betrachten mit
innovativen lösungen zu begegnen dies
wollen und müssen wir nutzen um
nachhaltige und klimaschonende
wirtschaften zu können ein beispiel
ein beispiel aus dem bereich
mobilität ist nahverkehr auf nachfrage
sowie in münster oder anderenorts ist es
bereits modellhaft umgesetzt nutzerinnen
können über eine app einem transport
wunsch angeben und dann wird dynamisch
die route von kleinbussen zusammengebaut
und transportiert die menschen von a
nach b und das verbesserte mobilität im
vor städtischen raum genauso wie im
ländlichen raum
alles klar haben wir in den letzten
jahren gut diese liste ließe sich lange
fortsetzen auf viele bereiche ausdehnen
zunächst aber sind wir als politik
gefragt und dann den booster von herrn
wissing zu zünden um nämlich die
rahmenbedingungen für digitale lösung
und für unternehmen zu verbessern um
alles umsetzen zu können und an dieser
stelle möchte ich noch mal zurückkommen
auf die wirtschaftspolitische debatte
von heute morgen da haben frau klöckner
und andere redner der union und
unterstellt dass wir die perspektive der
unternehmen nicht berücksichtigen würden
und das nur sich in aller schärfe zurück
fallen ich selbst bin bis zur wahl
unternehmer gewesen ich hatte die ehre
den wirtschaftspolitischen teil des
koalitionsvertrages mit zu verhandeln
und in der gruppe haben wir die
perspektive gerade von kleinen und
mittelständischen unternehmen immer auf
dem schirm gehabt und ich werde auch
dafür sorgen da hast du bleibst
bevor sie also noch mal versuchen uns
irgendwelche defizite anzudichten
bearbeiten sie bitte erstmal ihre
eigenen informationsdefizite
so so um also die voraussetzung zu
schaffen für digitale innovationen und
für nachhaltiges und digitales
wirtschaften von unternehmen um diese
innovationen umzusetzen haben wir eine
reihe von maßnahmen koalitionsvertrag
beschlossen und der kollege zimmermann
hat das so schön gesagt das wollen wir
gemeinsam umsetzen viele der punkte
wurden hier auch schon genannt so kann
ich mich also hier ein bisschen kürzer
fassen insbesondere danke ich frau
karski für die ausführung zum zu open
source software denn die adressieren wir
ja insbesondere mit dem souverän tech
fand
ein punkt ist aber noch wichtig und das
sind die freiheitsrechte die müssen wir
schützen und das ist ein spagat es geht
einerseits darum freiere sichere
verschlüsselte kommunikation und auch
den austausch in sozialen netzwerken
sicher zu stellen und andererseits aber
vor hass und hetze zu schützen und das
wollen wir vor allem erreichen durch
aufstockung der ressourcen und nicht
durch den verbot einzelner messenger wer
so etwas fordert der hat den sack martin
esel das bringt nichts herr präsident
ich komme zum schluss wir adressieren
die risiken sorgen für den nötigen
infrastruktur ausbauen und setzen die
rahmenbedingungen um digitalisierung für
nachhaltigen ökologischen und sozialen
fortschritt zu nutzen dankeschön
vielen dank herr kollege
aus dem dorf zu
rednerin zu diesen themenbereichen wird
die kollegin isabel gerade bathory
spd-fraktion sein für und mit ihrer
ersten beiden spielen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn menschen
zukunftsvisionen entwickeln spielt
mobilität seit jeher eine wichtige
wesentliche rolle raumschiffe menschen
die sich wie im fliegende autos die
frage wie der mensch sich fortbewegt hat
schon immer unsere fantasie an und die
gemüter aufgeregt nicht zuletzt in
meiner heimatstadt mannheim oder aus
vielen dieser vision realität das erste
automobil gebaut von carl benz vor im
sommer 1885 über die straßen mannheims
und bereits 1817 baute karl von drais in
mannheim das erste die erste zweirad
laufmaschine vorläufer des heutigen
fahrrads gestern und heute gilt
mobilität ist stets im wandel und genau
dieser wandel strikt von jeher danach
den menschen mehr und nicht weniger
mobilität zu ermöglichen
so soll es auch bleiben
die von der ampel koalition angestrebte
verkehrswende wird keine wende hin zu
weniger mobilität sein und schon gar
keine wende hin zu einer gesellschaft in
der mobilität zum luxusgut wird es ist
eine wende hin zu einer nachhaltigen
effizienteren und intelligenteren vor
allem aber auch weiterhin bezahlbaren
mobilität
es ist eine große errungenschaft unserer
industriegesellschaft mobilität und
damit auch eine neuartige form der
globalisierung für weite teile der
bevölkerung und nicht nur für eine
privilegierte minderheit zu ermöglichen
meine eigene lebensgeschichte die über
drei kontinente spannend ist ein zeugnis
dieser vernetzten welt und ich bin
deshalb auch persönlich nicht daran
interessiert diese entwicklung zurück zu
drehen in der zukunft brauchen wir eine
vielfältige und vernetzte mobilität die
alle verkehrsträger gleich ernst nimmt
denn die meisten bürgerinnen und bürger
bewegen sich nicht nur mit einem
verkehrsmittel fort sondern wechseln im
laufen einer einzigen woche mehrmals
zwischen fahrrad bahn auto oder fußweg
deswegen ist es ein erklärtes ziel der
ampelkoalition die investitionen in die
infrastruktur weiter zu erhöhen und
langfristig abzusichern und zwar nicht
nur in bayern verehrte kollegin
wir werden dem anderen
wir werden den wandel nicht von oben
verordnen sondern subsidiarität ernst
nehmen und kommunen mehr spielräume
einräumen um sind für sie richtigen
mobilitäts mix mit ihren bürgerinnen und
bürgern umzusetzen dabei dürfen wir
nicht vergessen mobilität prägt auch
identität verkehrspolitik ist kein
ausschließlich technisches thema über
antriebe infrastruktur und taktung
verkehr betrifft wirklich jeden menschen
in unserer gesellschaft und zwar jeden
tag aufs neue als spd werden wir dabei
insbesondere im blick behalten dass
mobilität nicht zu einer sozial frage
wird die die gesellschaft spaltet aus
technischen wandel werden der sozialen
fortschritt für alle schaffen wenn also
klimaaktivisten wieder über spd fahrer
herfallen autofahrer sich über
radfahrende aufregen und fußgänger über
e scooter schimpfen halten wir einmal
inne und denken daran was uns als
bürgerinnen und bürger verbindet wir
alle wünschen uns dass die bahn endlich
mal wieder pünktlich fährt in diesem
sinne gehen wir jetzt richtig gas
[Applaus]
soweit die debatte zu ministerium
digitales und verkehr